the big Straker peels off to the back
post he's not touching first time that's
incredible Sandy's top of he's gonna
smoke my sonís right in a row coos now
over now everybody's loving this Messi's
except two hot dogs for your back dog
[Music]
all the pressure is on at this moment in
time the stadium is full of young 80
ten-year-old and it is only Ratan
Ramanath the last check of the game is
incredible Schiller is just ending to
keep us killer yeah 10 here and he's
just ending them if I do not make sure
when they come off and one meet at the
corner flag that will not be me never
with me and a family I'd know get the
ball for a start for the peg knocks into
the edge of the box make most people did
he say get something the top shelf ice
incredible what up finish son mr.
Paignton edge of the box and big minds
backspin or via your other check what's
up finished the boys are in shock the
boys I'm shocked what a finish tion
right there if I've done that either in
good Street to the anything that is not
an Snodgrass ease textbook or leg
checked not a chance
you'll never see me they're not but fair
play effect of East produced an apps
like tracker they keep our eyes get full
of eggs and his hands and the big
straight curfews off to the bike course
he's not Church of first-timers
incredible stop
he's gonna smoke my sonís right in a
raucous realm of an hour everybody's
lover that thinks Messi's easier to
hotdogs for your bank dog incredible or
some beautiful even in for a talk on the
finish radio how they keep us on going
you're sailing make a name for yourself
Oh
[Applause]
not expect I was probably be always
fretting please get her in a pool cue
and it's a high awful pun up the park
looking for the big streaker clear the
way
no much do they look my store gets on
the boat twice Tom's guess I'll wait the
fuel price like these options like a
movie person and their anyway the last
wicket Falls turned the cheap bar is
working for us
taxi the ladies Dorf is took by them the
voice of buzzing happy days for yourself
what a big lie technique many people
have with the trick you touch their big
man fake snow not TV
I wanna get a go boss you know if they
won't say you won't say oh you just been
sent for the ball yeah yeah honestly
games over go right now get your stuff
yeah yeah but wait a mekinese 500 Davey
yeah that was one of the greatest
personal I think ever seen
it reminds me of a Phillippi Anderson
lands Enoch you know the ones you
compare the money and watch I speak of
it nests in there the local don't I fix
podcast
these are the exciting players the ones
that you know that's the ones that you
can get you up off your seat low throw
and boys like Phil of our movement
severe lack of movement or he's getting
a little straighter mumble tip and locks
it in the big dog except at first they
were finish what the finish
he's gonna answer is shushing the Sun
yeah done then Carles Puyol runs in
talking of jumping by crows mommy let's
just describe the technique here let's
finish it through him like a movie to
start off we but the big mind just peels
away these mind not track knees run up
he's playing why not and they're posting
stuff go on break that phosphate you
know what you just lean back along like
this here elevation order it's the
celebration I'm what well dance true for
ones it a little on yourself
goodbye to Nicky face bright Beckett ah
[ __ ] he's
he's took a whole football up Delaney's
to give a foster it's not what our
finished son yes
he's the honestly nice Beckham ask the
keeper is trick are asking as come off
is onion bhaji bunion is to convey touch
the boy is tender in knows where it's
gone Susan that's what it was when soon
as it leaves your foot you know exactly
he may as well just run straight to the
shallows and say yourself I am over here
that's the best pool I'm gonna squat and
son really incredible yes and thought
the play some of God alive with a bright
yellow top so he could stand her even
more with at a beautiful overhead cake
he's a fun place in second place I've
gotta live with his severe lack of
movement and start with the flow I'm but
he loses his mind then he gets unsaved
and he just fainted he sell
that's good straight and the top corner
he's in same place but he's dance also
well done that beautiful and fast placed
the ladders end in people's careers
leaves three nut meds in a row
he is trick the factory last week we my
skills well done son
you